good evening everyone
my name is mj and i'm part of the
migrant justice initiative project
at yale university i am so excited that
you joined us for today's book
conversation between
author carla cornejovi avicencio and
professor albert laguna
before we introduce each other we'd like
to acknowledge the stolen quinnipiac
land on which yale university stands
as well as the indigenous peoples and
nations that have historically cared for
and maintained the land which we now
call connecticut including the mohigan
mashintaket pica east urban peacock
shattuck
golden hill pakistan niantic and other
all goku and speaking peoples
a little bit about the migrants just as
an initiative we are multidisciplinary
project at the yale center
for the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration
that aims to establish relationships
between scholars and migrant-led
social justice campaigns our goal is to
engage in discussions of agency mobility
displacement
politics and culture from the
perspective of migrants in order to
better understand their realities and
the structures that shape them
our team currently includes alicia cathy
maldonado
ramon maggie katz and mj myself
and now i'd like to introduce our
moderator and our speaker for today
uh i'd like to begin with professor
albert sergio laguna
he's an associate professor of the
ethnicity race of migration and american
studies at yale university
his research and teaching interests
include transnational latinx literatures
and cultures comparative ethnic studies
performance studies and popular culture
studies
his work has appeared uh on for anna's
forthcoming and latino studies the
journal of latino
latin american cultural studies latin
american research review
contemporary literature cultural
critique diario de cuba the miami herald
the washington post and on cnn.com
laguna's first book diversion play in
popular culture in cuba and america
won numerous awards including the 2018
peter c rowlands book prize
from the northeast popular american
culture association
an article from his current book project
edgardo vega yunke and the comedy of
race was awarded to the ls dembele prize
for contemporary literature for best
article published in that journal in
2018
and then we have author carla cornejo
villavicencio who is an immigrant from
brooklyn and queens
harvard graduate yale phd student and a
writer who has contributed to the new
york times the new republic vogue
l glamour this american life and more
she is the author of the national book
award finalist the undocumented
americans
a book of essays and the upcoming young
adult novel dream girl she lives in new
haven with her partner and her very cute
dog
and now i'd like to pass it over to
professor laguna who will be moderating
the panel
hello everyone i'd ask you how you're
all doing you can maybe tell me in the
chat if you'd like
carla more importantly how are you doing
i am okay
hello good to see you good to see you
we had a little uh a frankie uh cameo
there before the
before the talk so i'm excited to to
have the whole kind of
um crew there along with you um
so you know carla a lot of people
on this call i'm sure i've read this
book uh but others have not
so i thought we could start with just a
really basic you
bringing us into the world of the
undocumented americans
why did you write this book and what is
it about what are you trying to do with
it
um i wrote this book as a
response to um having grown up with
representations of immigrants that i
didn't feel were
true to my community or my family
growing up
and i wrote it i began
uh researching and writing it the
morning after
trump won the presidency in 2016.
so it's very much like a snapshot in
time
um and i wanted to do something
different with genre
um i you know i'd always you know ever
since you're like in high school one of
the basic things you learn in like
english classes that like
um after like the a-bomb or after
something
like like a world war there was a
there was like a change in schools of
literature
and i felt that i didn't want to wait
around to see what would happen
um you know what would result of the
trump presidency like when i was
i was a child when 9 11 happened and
i remember people were wondering like
what would the 911 novel look like right
and i don't think they've been great but
i
i i do remember having a sense
that obviously things would be bad for
immigrants during the trump
administration
but also having a sense of what those
were
what those like literary works would
look like and wanting to
um provide an alternative
so i mean you're providing an
alternative um
to i guess what you imagined
the kind of fallout has been of the
trump presidency the narratives around
undocumented folks but
you're also providing uh uh an
important kind of intervention and
representations of the undocumented
immigrants more broadly i think
in in mainstream discourse you have this
great line which
reminds me um i don't need much of a
reminder how funny you are in this book
right there's moments of
really great lines uh cutting comic
lines
but you say quote uh you didn't want
this book to be a rueful
tale about a sickly victorian orphan
with tuberculosis who didn't have a
social security number
um so i'd love to hear a little bit more
about maybe like
the the biz side of this right how the
publishing in
the publishing industry in particular um
sells the narrative of latinx folks
undocumented immigrants more broadly uh
first second generation how you see the
book in conversation
uh with those demands and also if you
can just say a little bit about now that
the book has received a lot of positive
attention
you know what that experience has been
within uh the industry as you as you
continue to kind of
gain that visibility i mean can i just
say
i don't know who's on the call because
of the way this is set up
so um
um i'm feeling triggered right now
because
um i don't know how many of the people
here know
albert was one of my dissertation
advisors and
before then one of my professors and
he's known me since i was like 21 or 22.
and even though on instagram i say i'm
26 i'm 31
and so um so your tone
your teaching tone to me is
very um it just it just
brings me back to when i was like 23
and um crying in your office
um which i think in a lot of author
talks that doesn't happen
so i'm going to
try to answer your questions without
crying
um clarify first that so i don't get
hate mail that it wasn't because i was
mean to you that you're crying but
because we're having difficult
conversations
or maybe i wasn't me too you can clarify
no no because he's a mentor
and so it was like a mix of academic
queries and sharing texts and
this would be inspirational to you and
you might want to look at this resource
let's do outlines i always benefit from
outlines and also
just like i my twenties were a time
or were a decade-long fugue state and um
albert was there for it so um if there
are
any international inquirers here
albert is willing to tell
to tell it all um so
um what was your question what was the
question
yes i'm interested in the biz right
because we've talked about
the publishing industry kind of the
narratives they like to publish about
latinx communities undocumented
and not undocumented and just to hear a
little bit of how this book is
pushing back in conversation with those
demands and also you know
because this book has received national
book award right i mean it's getting a
lot of attention
and it's taking you probably into
conversations that you haven't had
before
in the industry i'd like to hear just
you know your experience with that
okay um well
it's i mean it's very interesting i
received pushback at every um
single step of trying to write this book
and
and publishing it and promoting it um
you know not not from
[Music]
there's some stuff that i can't say
because i'd like to continue to make a
living
throughout my life in publishing but um
the original draft of my book was at
another
imprint um that has now closed and
um they rejected the book because they
called it broken and unpublishable
and it's this book um and
i um and i asked why and
and i wasn't given a reason i was told
that i was going to be given a letter
explaining everything
and and i wasn't i was just given the
line edits and the line edits were
typical edits that were like you might
want to move this clause here
and so um
i won't reveal what happened later but
my editor
um protected my book and it ended up in
the hands of christopher jackson
who was an extraordinary editor at one
world who edits tomahawsi coates abram x
uh candy and um
and he um he really understood my voice
but it took him a lot
a lot of time to understand me you know
um and to understand um
[Music]
to understand that there could be
someone like me a dreamer like me
um who was who had different
different kinds of loyalties you know
and so
um while he supported my vision
he was a little bit confused by it and
probably had to do with me having a
difficulty articulating my vision
um but so um you know for instance the
the magical realism that's in the book
um
he thought that that was going to make
people not believe in the reporting of
the book
and some of the reporting is reporting
that i break
so like the stories of the 911 cleanup
workers
um is has been pretty underreported
um and he's like people are not gonna
believe that if that
if you're just like um you're making
things
up and like i was telling you earlier
albert
i thought elian gonzalez was rescued by
the dolphins
and i listened to a podcast recently
where they were talking about eliang
and they were like you know these people
thought that he was rescued by the
dolphins
and i was talking to my partner
who is a white woman and i was like um
i mean i thought i thought that until i
listened to the podcast
like i knew that that wasn't literally
real
but it is a kind of real i mean in the
sense that if a group of people
a large enough group of people believe
it and if their belief
leads to a conclusion that sustains them
then it is real
i mean it's a kind of real it's a kind
of reel that
um is that that has actual
um material consequences in people's
lives right
um and so uh the way i think about
magical realism
is is super specific and and
so i i i explained it and what we ended
up doing in the book
is every instance of magical realism
ended up being
a dream you know um but you know
every time for copy editors i you know i
i
received a lot of support in my imprint
from my editor but you know
copy editors proofreaders would circle
paragraphs in my book and say
are you sure you want to say this this
is vulgar or
are you sure you want to say this this
is like
this is um you know this is really
violent
or i don't think you i don't think you
want to publish something that says this
where i was like um revealing that i was
cruel to my brother
or i was revealing um
something dark but funny uh
like a fantasy that i had about drowning
a toddler which was not
real but it was um it still revealed
something about
my psyche and so i just had to there's
uh
um i don't know if if college students
do this but
when you're in editing you just do
stat if you want to reject and edit
and i was just i i take edits um
but when they're about tone that people
think that i shouldn't be using
because as an immigrant i am not
entitled to that tone
i just wrote stat stats that a lot
um and then we came up to promoting the
book
um you know the thing they wanted to
lead with was that i was
a harvard grad one of the first harvard
grads to go from you know
and i was like that doesn't position my
book as a literary book
that positions it as a dreamer memoir
which is not
i don't talk about harvard i don't talk
about yale
i don't talk about any of that like it's
um
i understood why they had to do it but
then i had to work behind the scenes
to sabotage the marketing plans and to
reach out to
individual people individual editors
individual publications
and say this is a literary book um
i have a ton of questions about the
literary aspect of this
uh book that i want to talk about but i
i do
want to put some more um
some more of the focus on uh
the kind of nuts and bolts um
and here i have a question about just
translation you know because i was
reading this book as
the second time around as a literary
work trying to understand
um different devices at work and just
one word that kept coming up
in my head was translation right um
and your comments right now make me
think of translation again right um
how it works as a concept in the book
you talk about your beef with
translation
in the context of journalists and often
how they have to they fail to convey the
complexity
of the language of their
spanish-speaking interlocutors you talk
about translation
in the context of someone like santiago
at the worker center who refuses to
translate
a pastor's sonny liberal takes on
america
then there's on your own approach to
translating um the words of the folks
you engage with right
um and translating your vision for a
broader readership
so and then i also want you to talk
about the question of translation
translating this book into spanish um
and how how that's going if it's going
and you know what your thoughts are
about it
so if you could riff a little bit about
translation as a kind of concept
in this book and and your relationship
to it i think that'd be really
interesting yeah
i mean i think that i first became
acquainted with translation
as a narrative that white audiences like
to hear immigrant children talk about or
children of immigrant talk about
like vis-a-vis our relationship to our
parents like we translate for our
parents that makes us special
and that makes us worthy of a special
kind of pity
but also a special kind of
attention and i'd like to like pull all
you know children of immigrants who've
applied to schools using translation as
part of their college entrance essay i
did i mean i didn't write about being
undocumented but i
wrote a short story which i wasn't
allowed to do
where i focused on translation
and also about lying also about lying
through translation
and um and then it you know dawned on me
now that i'm 31
and i'm working on my healing that
translation from the time that you're
very young from the time that you're
five years old
and not just basic translation but like
writing your own
absence notes translating for your
report cards
translating at your own therapist
appointments
translating um at your mother's
gynecological appointments where you may
hear things about your dad that you
rather not know
that's all part of like this
parentification thing that children of
american
immigrants go through which is
not our parents fault it is part of the
system
that we've fallen into um that is this
monster
of migration and it is
not blaming anyone to acknowledge that
migration
where the the powers that are supposed
to protect us and create
laws to guarantee that we have humane
and dignified lives
have neglected us and so that we the
children
often have to become parent figures to
our parents
and so translation is very fraught and
it's not the romantic
sweet thing that um white admissions
officers think it is
and so yeah translation was interesting
to me in the book and
i um it was interesting to me as a
writer
because whenever i've read um pieces of
journalism that have
trans like literally transliterated
spanish english to spanish to english
they um there's no art in the
translation
and so they just like use like
one word for one word and it's they make
us
all sound like we have a kindergarten
level
language capability with absolute no
nuance
and absolute no sense of humor absolute
no sense of interiority
and i'm like that's not how we sound
like you know
because when you read us in the spanish
paper when you read us in el diario
like we're we're we're shady we're
like sassy we have conspiracy theories
like
why don't we sound like that in the
english paper and
um so my approach to translating in this
book was
well as a child of immigrants my thing
is translating right
so i translated for my subjects the way
that i did for my parents
so in real time
in real time and um when it was time for
me to
um and i didn't use recorders because
this was like
2016 and people i did not want to scare
people
um i as as like edith grossman who
translates for like garcia mark
marquez and stuff we're translating for
garcia marcus and stuff
um you have like a certain number of
words that you could use to translate
why choose the simplest word to make you
sound
like what you think we are which is like
the simplest possible common
person when you have these other words
that you could translate
so because i'm not an actual translator
or an actual journalist
i chose a word that conveyed what i
thought the person
meant felt like
if they were angry and that sort of like
the spirit of the person i got to know
my subjects really well
and um so when you
hear when you see their text in my book
it sounds like you talking to someone
that you know in your language
um and i didn't make any text up i
didn't make any dialogue up
it's their words i just translated the
way that a poet would translate
uh you know literary language which is
you do some rewriting but you don't add
um you just choose the most beautiful or
the most evocative
choices which i thought was a way of
giving back some dignity to our
community which has been infantilized
um and another thing yes my translation
so my book
is written in english i my maternal
language is
um spanish but i the language i write in
and think in is
english and um
i mean i don't know if i can talk about
this but whatever so like my
my book was was going to be translated
into spanish
and they hired a latin american
[Music]
a white latin american translator for
the spanish translation so i spoke to
this person and i said my book has my
philosophy on translating
and she said i don't agree and i said
okay you do you boo
but like this is a very clear voice
in my book like it's very voicey and
also my um
my readers are going to be like
immigrants and people connected to
immigrants
like i'm from new york like i you know
and so i get their
the the translation back and it's in
this like sort juana ines de la cruz
aristocratic spanish like
okay so i'm at the yale
american studies phd program i applied
to two american studies phd programs in
english
harvard and yale everything else i
applied for was spanish phd programs
or latin american phd programs in
spanish
like i get i get it i got i got it
um she thought it was the editors
thought it was a class thing
he told me like we can try to get this
to um
sound more like street spanish and i was
like excuse me sir
do you know that latinx spanish is a
different vernacular
than latin american aristocratic spanish
sir
and and then it just wasn't worth my
time because like i said i'm on a
healing journey
and i just don't waste that energy like
shakira says in that song
you don't throw pearls to the pigs you
know i was not going to change his mind
my editor tried to speak on my behalf
and say
carla's right like dude you have to get
a different translator
you know what he said to me the typical
response of racist white men
who say that there are no qualified
candidates he said that he
couldn't find a latinx translator a
qualified latinx translator
and i said cuny has a program
for translation
and um and then he he was difficult
about it and he said no so i so i pulled
the translation
and i i just knew the book was going to
continue to be more successful and i was
going to win more awards
and i was going to have my choice of
translator at some point
because like what's the point of
publishing a book
that's going to sound like
like an argentine on ecstasy
masturbating to himself
this book is written by and for
latino immigrants and immigrant adjacent
if it's not going to sound like that
then it doesn't exist
okay i think we have the title of your
next book there you know our next
hard-hitting article
about the reception of this book um
and you know this it's actually really
interesting to hear that right because
it gives you a sense of
you know when you think of uh how a book
like yours
makes it through the world of the us
publishing industry you know you ever
think about the kind of translation of
the spanish aspect
of it i think that's that's very telling
and perhaps not too surprising
you know i really appreciate that riff
on on translation and it really just
hits home like how um
how well you do the job of translation
because you know the measure for me for
that is that
i remember the people distinctly that
you talk about and you're
speaking with in your book right uh it's
not just like a mass of people
right with different stories i remember
names and like situations and that's
because
you're giving us a person through their
words right and that's
and that's because of your your skill as
a translator right
um uh so you know
i want to illuminate that a bit more uh
your relationships with these people
because it's such a big
part of the book it's what makes the
book the book right
um so i'd love for you to say a bit more
about how you made those connect
connections develop that intimacy but
you know i'd really
i'm more interested secretly not so
secretly in the failures
of connection that you talk about um
you talk about it in a couple of ways
right and i think it's really important
you don't shy away from the fact that
you failed
multiple times right to connect with
people right and i think those failures
are dare i say generative right so
i'd love to hear more about that the
relationships you cultivated and you
couldn't cultivate right i think that's
a fun story which relationships are
speaking about well i always think about
the
the when you're in is it cleveland and
or is no flint when the students
um you're like let's go to new york they
just kind of like looked at you and you
the trouble you had connecting
with uh some of the the teenagers
pre-teens um yeah link context
um i mean you know you you bring a lot
of
commonalities and and kind of common
ground with these people to connect with
but they're also big differences right
your life trajectory and the people
you're speaking with so
um uh yeah i'd love to hear about those
relationships because they are
core right to the book so that was very
the fluent chapter was very painful for
me to write
because it's something that i
that is unresolved within me and i know
um
again i have no idea who's on this call
other than
alicia's face and steve's um ass big ass
on the screen but
um i i know a lot of you
you know latinx youth who are here at
yale might
be able to relate to this but when
you've heard from the
you know from your earliest memories
that the way of getting out
is through education and it just happens
through
strokes of luck and genetic accidents
that you have no control over
and work ethic but you also know that
your like uncle has incredible work
ethic
and your undocumented aunt has
undocumented that works at walmart has
great ethic and then you're like well
it's not just a work ethic right
and you understand that it's just like
kind of russian roulette
and um and you're like okay so i i did
this i did this
the right way and um
and then as you grow older you
realize that it changes a lot of things
and it doesn't change a lot of things
so um you know so some like right wing
websites
like you know try to take me on
and be like the way to fame and fortune
is to be an illegal alien
and it's like well i am i'm a queer icon
now
but i definitely don't have no fortune
um
and it's um i know that college
is not the answer for everybody
but i also have a knee-jerk reaction
if a young person comes up to me and
asks for advice
to say go to four-year school quarter
four-year school
uh i can't not
and if a young person says
that they want to do something in art i
need to know what their art looks like
and i need to personally evaluate if i
think that they are
going to be able to make money off of it
and if i don't think they are i will
break their [ __ ] heart
and say i think you can do this as a
hobby
but i think you should go into
engineering you know
and a lot of people including my partner
think i'm a monster
um she teaches in education studies and
so
you know she has a lot of kids of color
who want to be teachers
and sometimes i get them on the sly and
i'm like
hey have you thought about law school
you know um and it's just because
i know a lot of these kids have to
support their parents
until they die and i worry about how
they're going to be able to do that on a
public school teacher salary
on an elementary school public teacher
salary and it's not my business
but i also just worry and
i haven't solved it for myself because
i took an arts career um
i'm doing okay in terms of um
recognition laurels but i'm not making
money off of it
and but i've also been lucky enough to
support my parents throughout the
pandemic
and and that's it i sort of feel like
like that is uh you know like the jlo
movie enough where she was just
like does all of the like
all of the like the the physic like all
of the training to get ready to beat her
abuser
i was like i did all of this to be able
to support my parents
because i knew a pandemic was coming and
they needed to live off of me
because otherwise they would literally
die
and um and i want all of these children
of immigrants who come to me asking for
advice or who don't
i want them to be able to have that at
the same time
i don't want them to be unhappy and
choose careers that
kill their souls and so that's the
fluent chapter
where i try to
reach out to young teens and say like
look at me don't you don't you have big
broadway dreams
and they're like no i i mean i want to
just
that place has great tips and they
probably make more money than i do
but then i like i i'm like really
heavy-handed and i'm like have you
thought about health insurance
i've thought about savings and and i
just can't help but be that person
because of my traumas and and i thought
that the on the most honest way to
handle that
instead of somehow pretending that i've
solved that for myself
um is just being
totally like we say in spanish
just being like look i'm a product of
programs like prep for prep and i'm
a product of knowing that i was went
hungry as a child
and that i had this one thing that i was
good at
that it turns out i could make money
from and now i want
it's sort of like i remember kendrick
lamar saying in an interview
that he i mean what he does now is that
he hires a lot of
talented kids from compton to work for
him
and i don't know how that's going but he
says that like the first time that he
was at a nice hotel
he wished that he could just like like
fly in
all the kids from compton and just put
them in that one hotel
and i think it's a lot of survivor's
guilt and i think it's a lot of
hoping that the magic spell that worked
for you
even a little worked for everybody else
and i think a lot of
people struggle with it and i think that
no one wants an answer but
acknowledging the struggle is um what a
lot of people needed
i think i mean it's important for you to
say that
and say it out loud my next question was
going to be about that
tension between the you know the
password for the for the for the kids in
uh outside of cleveland right study hard
and your anxieties about giving that
kind of the
the advice about education but
it's it's unless it's i think it's
important to hear because so much of the
stories follow your dreams do what you
love but
for a lot of people they can't or
it's it's not that easy to make that
decision so i to show that you're
wrestling with it i think is
in the book is really it's really
important productive
um you know i want to move now looking
at the clock to
the question of this book as capital l
literature right uh and art
right um because i think that's such an
important uh part of this book a
contribution that it's making is that it
will be the subject of many
english uh phd uh dissertations
there's not enough there oh yeah oh yeah
don't worry it's all right i'm already
starting to assign it um
so it's the pipeline you know we're
working on that pipeline
um someone has to be the uh the carla
cornejo
avicencio chair of american studies
somewhere hold up please don't
i'll send a cease and desist
[Laughter]
well um i think i just want to take a
line from your intro right and i want to
ask you to unpack it a bit right where
you say
quote when you're an undocumented
immigrant with an undocumented family
writing about undocumented immigrants
and i can only speak for myself and my
ghosts
it feels unethical to put on the drag of
a journalist it is also painful to focus
on the art
but impossible to process the world as
anything but art and quote
so i just want you to just unpack what
does it mean to process this world that
you're writing about as
art why is that important and if you can
clarify even what's the creative
in creative nonfiction right that you're
kind of harnessing
uh in this narrative well
i mean it for me was important to you
know i
um studied under kate dudley at yale and
so i had an understanding of like
ethnographic writing and even like
ethnographic creative writing and
ethnographic fiction
but um so i referred to my subjects as
my subjects
but i also while i was writing my book i
made a conscious
decision to write about them as
characters because i wanted them to be
like really rich people who you know had
uh
had had heft had had weight and
so it's sort of like when you build a
character from scratch
and i'm now that i'm writing a novel it
feels harder to do
with a novel um but i wrote them as
characters
i wanted them to hold up to
to scrutiny um and in order to do that i
have to do a lot of interviews
where i just didn't ask them how many
times did you cross the desert
do you send remissions to your family
like
what does it mean to be american that's
not how you write
a character right that's how you sort of
fill out a census form
so what i did was i just talked to them
about just really boring things
and just like not a lot happens in my
book there's not really much plot
um like one of the stories that people
seem to respond to a lot and one of
the loveliest conversations i had was
with i forgot his the name i give him in
the book because i changed everyone's
names but
a man in the flint chapter who worked at
a chocolate factory
and who had two pipples and that's
all i say about him really he worked at
a chocolate factory and then he got
fired and he gave his filtered water to
his
two pit bulls and usually in a story
where you have like in a piece of of art
about immigrants you want like a story
you want there to be trauma you want
there to be action you want there to be
but there nothing happens here it's just
that
but the way that i was able to write
about him and sort of like a slow
sort of pace that um
people really responded to was that i
am you know i sort of built him up like
a paper doll
um and and i
i i cared about him and i think you can
tell that when you read the book and
i thought what made him so special was
that
um people think about us as people who
will do jobs
americans won't do we're just like
really hard workers or like whatever
but here's a man who took like great
delight and great dignity and having
this really
um this job that he loved with these
fantastic smells
and where at the end they thought that
they could infantilize him
by giving him a certificate that was
like you were you did great bud
when they fired him for no reason and
and the fact that when people think of
undocumented immigrants they're not
going to think that someone loved his
rescue pitbull so much that
that they would give him they would give
them their own filtered water
during a water crisis no one's gonna
think that you know that is such a
beautiful humanizing detail and um
and i thought that says so much that
says that's so much
and um yeah
so it was you know it was things like
that that i think
really build up a character so for me it
wasn't about
representing subjects because
representing subjects for me i think
could be just like
you already have in your mind what you
want to say about them like hard working
you know you know family values
pays his taxes you know whatever
but i wanted to see what was
what was you know what made that person
special and everything you know there's
good special bad special weird special
but
every person has a little something and
so
um i just treated people as characters
and i think that's what made it creative
yeah i think you know when you're
talking about the smells since you
began talking about this this person i
was instantly transported to
kind of sensory experience of reading
that text i can almost smell
the floor of the that fact factory candy
factory right
um so again effect effective
and i'm kind of you know i want candy
now um
so if i can ask you to go a little bit
more on this kind of
this question of creativity right i want
to ask you about the moment that people
always ask you about right um the way
you imagine
uh the the death of ubaldo cruz martinez
right uh because i'm particularly
attracted to um
where you say on uh after you relate his
story after
drowning in a basement in uh with
hurricane sandy
you say what if this is how in the face
of so much sacrilege and slander
we reclaim our dead it's the question of
imagination and art
is how i'm kind of filling in the uh
kind of connecting the dots here
so can you say a little bit about that
moment because it is such a i think
key moment for unpacking the way kind of
creativity is working in this text and
how you
think the work of creativity what do you
think why do you think it's important
um you know i just
he was um his is the only
only occasion in the book where i use
someone's real name
um i use pseudonyms for everyone except
for him
i all of the day laborers that i knew
and i became very close to
the day laborers in staten island
most of them knew him or knew of him and
when i talked to them about him
there was a sense of slight
i guess there was a lot of sadness with
slice slight embarrassment because
of the way he died and what was
originally in the book
and i cut out was
for no reason other than space or just
editing was that
um if i died right now
if i was just like a freak accident
slipped and hit my head um
because because of who i am um
which is just like a a loudspoken
person who is unapologetic about
being um undocumented
an autopsy or you know
um the results of that would probably
be made political um
and what it would reveal is
like up for literary interpretation you
know
i'm on a lot of medications in order to
keep me alive
and given the day given how hard things
are
given how unstable or kind or
unboundaried my parents are given the
political news of the day
like aside from the medications i'm on
which laymen people men don't have
understanding of like and some of those
medications are scary sounding
like antipsychotics right they don't
know what they're treating
they're they're used off label to treat
my borderline personality disorder
but there's also you know i might have a
benzodiazepine in my system
i might have taken a drink i might have
had a lot of kombucha
which might represent for some level of
alcohol
you know i might have taken a beta
blocker because that stops my panic
attacks because it slows down my heart
rate
um you know i
uh it might have been a day where i had
a really big deadline that night and i
might have taken an adderall
and if someone did a toxicology report
they would have said like look at your
little dreamer
you know look at all the substances
she's on
and nobody deserves to have a toxicology
report
or any phase in their life define who
they are
or what their journey in this country
has been like
because like albert you know me like i'm
doing okay now but there have been times
in my 20s and during yale
where i was not doing okay and i did not
handle my mental health issues well and
my mental health issues
were intimately tied to my migration and
the fact that i did not know they were
tied to my migration
and i was sort of walking around blindly
and i did not receive culturally
sensitive mental health treatment for
them
and and i was you know i fell asleep in
coffee shops
i passed out in places i like vomited
blood outside of lecture halls
what if like that had been the moment
where i had become public
and that had been the name people
remembered me by
so once you have that in your head
you understand that migration
affects us all as we are all migrants
in the sense that we are all migrants
and
um and i didn't think it was fair that
that was his death
because um
a lot of people drink during storms he
died
he was drinking during the hurricane a
lot of people drink during storms
and it just happened that he died and so
i thought that
as someone who has total power over what
i put on the page
um i could either report it the way that
newspapers reported it
which was this alcoholic day labor were
drowned
because he was you know because of vice
or because of the understanding that i
had about the life
that migration takes on a body and on a
mind and a soul
i could envision a different ending for
him
and it was a reclamation and i felt that
that reclamation was for him
personally because my heart dictated
i make it but it was also for me
it was also a reclamation for the
different people i have been in my life
and the kind of
political pinata i could have been at
different points in my life or could
still be
you know it was in the end it was
an artistic call for compassion and
empathy
and also a reminder to my less than
sympathetic readers
that so long as they are holding my
pages i am
god and i control what happens in this
book
that's that's really great that you know
now i'm going to read that scene
with a with a new set of eyes um i
really appreciate that
uh that explanation um
and also just you know that moment in
the book just
it's pushing back against so much of
even the literature and latinx studies
or mainstream discourse which is
you know we try to count the
undocumented it's about policies it's
about like
it's about labor right so like making a
space
for for art and the imagination i think
is is so important to
what i love about this book so much um
you know i have some let's see what time
it is 5 50.
um this is kind of a it's just a it's
kind of a me question i just really want
to know
uh writing this book was clearly not
easy
um so i'm really curious just because
uh i want to get in your head a little
bit here about what you were listening
to and reading
while you were working through this um
i'm very curious um
at the beginning i read a lot of james
baldwin to
muster up the courage to write this
because i lo i mean i love his writing
obviously
but i also knew that he had a reluctance
to write about
some of the things he did because it
affected him immensely
and he felt that it was an obligation to
give back
as he said to the people who made him um
to the people who he owed and so i read
a lot of him
um and then i mostly stopped reading i
read some jenny diskey
because i liked the her voice but i
um and i read a lot of eileen miles who
became a friend
and i love eileen's um
i love eileen's voice and there's sort
of nobody who can
nobody's books who i read and then
go i really wanna write now you know
other than eileen um but mostly i listen
to a lot of music
and i think um you can sort of tell with
the cadence of my sentences that i was
going for something
that was um kind of disjointed and um
chaotic but also really tightly
controlled something that was like
written and then played chaotically and
so
um i listened to a lot of um
like the white stripes and i listened to
a lot of fiona apple
um and i listened to um
a lot of nirvana and the arctic monkeys
and um it's so funny the arctic monkeys
have
the songwriter alex turner he writes
some
really weird lyrics that if i tried to
write
would totally be get edited out but if i
can say
is that like everything that i tried to
edit out
everything that anyone tried to edit out
of this book any sentence
and that i fought for have now become my
reader's favorite
sentences or passages so
that's now i have a soundtrack for when
i reread the book i appreciate that i'm
taking notes here
um so maybe two or three more questions
before we open up to the q a
um i'm gonna ask you kind of fiendishly
uh to go back to your your your tf
days right i'm curious about how would
you teach
this book or if you don't wanna answer
that question you know
uh maybe the question is you know what
do you want leaders in college maybe to
get out of this book but if you want to
put on the tf hat you you're more than
welcome to do that
like i have no recollection of my time
as a tf
and sometimes like students i mean
they've graduated but like
they would have been like hey and i'd be
like hey
i did not remember any of them um so
um i i want you know what you know
what's crazy i
am i i have gotten a lot of messages
from
young people uh college students who
are saying that they are um
comfortable experimenting with the essay
form
and with first person writing and like
that's based on
heavy research and interviews and that
their professors are actually
encouraging them to do
creative projects and
personal essays based on a lot of
interviews
and reportage and research
and all of these kids who write me are
kids of color
and i think that that's fantastic um i
have like
throughout high school until now
i have forced that to be the case for me
in all of my classes um but
um the fact that i think um
you know i have a friend who's a who's
an immigration journalist and she just
got her first book deal and she said
that her editor
told her like cited my book and said
that she was allowed to write in the
first person
which before as a journalist you were
not allowed to do
um and so i think that
even though my book is still not like
huge
you know it's been really a grassroots
support of
a lot of latinx people and a lot of
immigrants and children of immigrants
and
people of color who supported the book i
i think that a lot of people who are
assigning the book
or in the publishing industry have
i don't know why i took them so long but
have noticed
that this is something you can do and
are
validating the genre of the personal
essay that's based
on reporting and uh
interviews and you know pop culture
references and all of this
uh genre that i worked with and um
they you know it's kind of like when
dave eggers released a heartbreaking
work of staggering genius and there were
like
a lot of date beggars after that you
know i was one of them
[Music]
so so in the future when i teach your
book i'll say i'll
send you my students comments and you
know reader responses
so you can you can be in the kind of
room as a tf right um
but uh you know you mentioned a little
bit about your the response that the
book has
uh received your direct messages about
students
feeling an ability to experiment form
and genre can you say a little bit more
about that grassroots support
and um uh there's responses from from
folks you're
you're getting yeah i mean at first i
was the only one who bet on this book
like nobody believed in this book um
my editor loved my voice but i don't
think he understood
that this book was as special as it was
it was
entirely latinx readers on social media
who discovered this book and not just
like
young people in their college checking
their colleges but it was like from
college age to like
children um like older
much older children of like the original
braceros
who were like i've been waiting my
entire life to see a book like this
who were really emotional and would like
send me videos of them
unboxing my book and um
and then like the younger kids would be
like
sending videos of them twerking to my
book and um
it was i mean it was really amazing um i
got messages from
um black immigrants african immigrants
who
just felt like they didn't really belong
in
the latinx activist movement because of
its
politics that i haven't really aligned
myself with
and they felt a little bit excluded from
the black lives matter movement
and they really found a home in my book
and
i've gotten a lot of messages from like
children of asian immigrants who really
love the book
i've gotten messages from
disabled readers who have felt
uh comfortable with the fact that
so much of what makes someone documented
not documented citizen not citizen smart
not smart
good at sats all of this is luck and
they understand that the role that luck
can play in a person's life and the way
that like
luck can determine whether or not you're
discriminated against or not for the
rest of your life
um and i you know i've i've
had a lot of um you know really
successful
uh latin latinx children of immigrants
understand um
my brain and and share it and share that
with me
and also you know i'm very open on
instagram about my mental illness
and um how hard work it is
to stay high functioning and stable
and to um
how sometimes we we judge whether or not
we're doing okay with our mental health
by how productive we are
but i also try to make sure that i find
um some space for joy every day and i've
had a huge response of latinx kids being
like
i am not doing well and i um
you know want to work on my mental
health and that's meant the most to me
so thank you for that my last question
before we get to
the q a is just uh you know what's
what's the next thing
you know you teased it a little bit
sounds like a novel
um i'd love to hear a little bit more
about that and maybe what
you know to focus on the art again right
that shift from
the undocumented america undocumented
americans to
um the novel as a form love to hear
about that as well
yeah the novel it's a young adult novel
um
and it it's sort of
loosely based on my teenage years in new
york city
writing about music as a teenager and
like being in
that underground the undocumented
underground and
the like you know multiple undergrounds
in new york
and it's like a very fast-paced gritty
pre-gentrified new york book um
it's a it's it's a if a beatnik
was a queer undocumented jehovah's
witness girl
in brooklyn um who
was rescued by a public masturbator
by a drag queen before her jehovah's
witness dad picked her up
at midnight at a jazz club in the
village
like that's the novel and then after
that i have a book of essays on
cults
um yes q a
let's go to the to the q a um the first
question is
one attendee notes your interest in
shifting the spotlight from the dreamer
and on to the everyday undocumented
immigrant can you say more about how we
might continue these efforts on a
nationwide political
level i have no policy recommendations
i mean i don't know um
if you're genuinely interested if you're
like someone who works on
in in policy spaces or like in activism
spaces
you can contact jose antonio vargas
he does that sort of how to get from
hearts and minds to politics
i don't do that sorry but what you do
is so important is that you're giving
people you know they're going to be
people
you know in 15 10 15 years probably even
sooner or later stage where the
undocumented americans is really
important for me right you're opening up
a space for people to imagine
be uh this community these communities
right in different ways right i think
that's
that's perhaps not um that's not a
policy uh
memo but it is extremely important as
you know
as people in humanities at least like to
think uh i include myself
among them um okay so more questions
can you say more about the cover image
of the book this is from
laura wexler
hi moroexler um yes
so the the the updated cover image of
the book
is um oh i have it here um
so everyone can see it um it's
it's this flower and here are
um the uscis documents uscis which is
being bankrupted
intentionally stephen miller brainchild
and then there are blood stains which i
requested to be all around there
um and so um
i didn't have any control over why that
flower was there
the flower was always there and i was
like okay um
and um i then came up with the
explanation that it was like
like i've always written about animals
and wildlife
in inhospitable places like the sonoran
desert or
under like the deepest fathoms of the
sea and compared undocumented people to
that because
we survive in hospitable climates that
want a stat right
so i think that's what they derived
inspiration from and then i wanted the
papers thing
with the blood because as someone who's
gone through daca
got a temporary green card that expired
um i think
a lot of people who have experienced
who've been undocumented and have
experienced legalization
or who have been citizens and then had
to petition their parents for
legalization
and then now in this era has seen that
fall through
all of that um there's a lot of guilt
there's a lot of survivors guilt there's
a lot of guilt
and you always feel like you have blood
on your hands
and i wanted to acknowledge the fact
that one
immigrants are world makers we make
worlds
out of thin air and two the
idea of papers having papers is always
in the background
but even when you have it it never goes
away the trauma doesn't go away and the
feeling that
you've left people behind doesn't go
away
so another question what are the things
you do
for joy how do you find joy when things
feel harder than ever
um you know what's a funny thing um this
is well albert you don't know this but
when i was albert's uh grad
student i was like 23 or 24. i used to
go to his office
clearly looking a mess and albert would
like
like like slide over a ziploc bag of
calming herbal tea to me
be like i think you should take this
home
um and okay so one of the things that i
do now is i try to find like
sensory things that i can look forward
to every day
so one of the things is like showering
and putting on
like fragrant body lotions and body oils
because that's like a mindful thing that
if you disassociate which
if you have trauma you probably do in
some way um it connects you to your body
and it also
you know connects you to your senses i
also drink a lot of like
turmeric tea um and it's kind of like a
pavlovian thing
where like alcohol um reminds me
of like i'm about to make a call to my
dad and i need to calm down my nerves
but whereas like turmeric tea a turmeric
latte
um which is just putting turmeric thing
in like water and then putting some milk
in it
it it reminds me that i'm taking care of
myself
so the more that i do it the more it
becomes
a reminder to myself that i'm taking
care of myself
um i'm working on
finding joy um i like birds
we should have talked more with albert
about birds um
so i like feeding them and um
i have this book by what's sibley's
first name
david david sibley has a
[Music]
so i read sibley's uh books on birds
when i'm feeling like super stressed and
triggered because
birds are beautiful and resilient
so find something that's not immigration
related
not don't be like okay so i'm going to
take care of myself i'm going to read
andre lord
no like find like birds before
when i used to be really crazy i used to
watch videos
of grizzly bears just like
just take humans out of the picture
just just look at a leaf you know
i really recommend that i i second the
birds
and for those of you wondering what tea
i was pushing in my office
it was um dilo which is in english
linden lindenflower wow uh yes it's good
call me t i
drink a lot of it that's why i was in my
office um
so um another question can you say a bit
more about your writing process
where and how you write how you manage
moments when the writing is not flowing
um well when i have like a lot of time
i'm like i pretend that a lot of things
matter
such as like inspiration and
i like you know ultimately
um all of it is [ __ ] and when you
have when you're on deadline all that
matters is
like that you sit down and you write so
um
what helps is an outline it
what helps the most is an outline so i'm
writing a piece
for the new yorker right now and my
editor made me an outline
and when i don't have someone making me
an outline my partner talia makes me an
outline and when i had the book what i
did was i
printed out chapters of the book and i
cut
um i don't know if you know this i cut
out paragraphs all the paragraphs
and sometimes individual sentences and
then
i um would tape them on my floor
in the order in which they were meant by
the gods to appear
which is actually um the way nobody's
wife
organized as index cards because he
would write his book in index cards
and then she reorganized them in the way
they were supposed to appear
because i am not a linear thinker and so
outlines help a lot
talia my partner is a fantastic teacher
and she makes all her students do
outlines
so i would say like i believe in like
burning palo santo candles skin
care moisturizing doing my makeup hair
like like matcha all of that until like
i'm on a deadline
and then i just like put on a one-piece
bathing suit
and just sit on my bed and just do it
well this is a related question um
because it's what
part of what makes your writing so
distinctive is that your voice right um
how did you can you tell us more there's
a question can you tell us more about
the process you've gone through to
develop and refine
your distinctive writerly voice
yeah um i think one of the things you
first start doing is you start
um first you discover things you don't
like
voices you don't like so albert knows
that i spent most of my time
as a grad student being like i hate this
i
hate this and then i would list
everything that i hated um
and um i wish i had spent more time
finding out things that i liked
um so at first i think as a young writer
you write against things and you um
and you shouldn't spend the rest of your
career doing that because some people do
some people do just just
develop a voice that's just like
anti-things but then they don't develop
a voice of their own
i would say read a lot um but not only
like novels or books
but like good tv writing like uh i was
obsessed with 30 rock i watched it like
seven
straight through and um that's like
there's like i think there's like
there's like
like a record number of references per
minute and like my writing is
very reference heavy so like that really
inspired me
um like a lot i watched a lot of snl
that inspired me a lot of rock and roll
that inspired me
like anywhere that's good writing like
good writing can also be
like um i remember when i was little
this is not no longer the case but when
um
vitamin water first came out the copy
the back copy of what vitamin water used
to be pretty witty
and i i remember being like in the fifth
grade and being like i want to write for
vitamin water one day
you know like wherever you can find good
writing like not just books but just let
it inspire you
and that's where your voice is going to
be like expansive
so that's why i tell kids like if you
are like latinx and you want to be a
writer don't
just read like anzaldua you know what i
mean
just don't read just like read expanse
watch movies
watch movies but don't just watch like
classics watch like
watch everything watch paris is burning
you know like
like watch videos on how to vogue and
realize like what different storytelling
looks like
you know um like watch
big performances i like watching big
performances like
yeah homecoming beyonce's homecoming
like freddie mercury
like how is a good performance how is
like storytelling done
and i think that's how you pick up like
a lot of like
influences and then when you sit down on
the page
you can be you but i'll tell you the
truth the first when i first started
writing i used to sit down and i used in
order to get
me hyped up to write i used to be like
okay
such and such essay by laurie moore such
and such essay
by joan didion and i used to try to um
imitate their voices and i think that
was a good exercise
because then you can see what like
ticks they have what tricks they have
and so like i can do
pretty good parodies of like hemingway
fitzgerald
joan didion garcia marquez all of them
and
like gertrude stein who is a huge
influence of mine
partly because i learned to parody her
so maybe like try to parody some of your
favorite
writers and then i don't know i i don't
know
you should not take life advice from me
but that's the stuff that i did when i
was younger
i i want to read the the parodies of
these of fitzgerald hemingway stein i
want to read that reminds me of
uh renaldo arenas does that for like the
canon of cuban writers in a book called
so i would love to read carla's version
of this for the candidate of american
literature the hemingway one is up on
mcsweeny's is it
have i seen it already i've probably
seen it oh okay more on that later
um so the questions are you know jumping
around topics that's fine that's why we
have a q a
um so another question asks can you talk
about how you navigated these immigrant
spaces from your interviews to your
personal interactions
as someone who is open and unapologetic
about mental health and queerness
queerness yes um
okay so this pixie is new
and i didn't look like this when i went
on my interviews
but um i was open i was open
um so um so i'll be sincere
so first of all for all of the day
laborers
um they had an organizer who is named
pedro in the book
who is gay and openly gay and the way he
organized them was to be like if you are
discriminated against here are other
groups who are discriminated against
in the day labor worker center there are
groups for lgbtq
people there are groups for trans people
so they knew that they that they had to
be respectful you know and they all
love him it was a complete safe space
for me
and um i had never i had
like with all the people that i spoke to
and most of the people that i spoke from
my book were men
i had one experience and it was with an
american citizen
where i felt uncomfortable as a woman
it was over text it was everyone was
completely appropriate with me
and um so i would i think that people
really
felt something that helped was that i i
pitched them the book
so um the pitch that i gave like the
publishers to sell them
was the pitch that i gave immigrants um
i wanted them to understand why i was
writing because a lot of them had
experiences with people from
lagunivision and telemundo
coming taking their pictures to getting
interviews and then like bouncing and
then never seeing them again
and that's not what i wanted to do like
i still have some people that i love who
are
in these communities that i check in on
them and make sure
that they're doing okay during covet
that they you know that
i i want to make sure that that i that
they can count on me
should things become catastrophic and
i um i didn't tell them that at the time
but i
um went into the communities and i was
like look so my name's carla
i um am on daca i am a
dreamer i don't identify as a dreamer
here's why i don't identify as dreamer
my parents are undocumented i have a
complicated relationship with my parents
here's why i was like this is the book i
want to write here's why books that i
have written about migrants that i've
read
i feel fall short here's why i think
we have not been represented in a way
that i'd like to see us represented
here's why i think i can do that
differently do you trust me to try
and i i felt like it would have been
condescending for me to just be like hey
can i interview about your life
without telling them what i was trying
to do with their stories
and they responded really well to that
you know they were like
yeah people think we're alcoholics yeah
people and i think like in one of my
chapters where
it's like middle-aged women who are like
yeah we're tired of our husbands we
marry too young like
i'm having like a like a feminist
awakening now and i want to go party
like that would not have been possible
if i had not told them that i was trying
to
change stereotypes and caricatures of
immigrants
they would have just been like yes so we
are we are activists you know they would
have told me the story they thought i
was trying to get
and um so one was that another thing is
that like my spanish is a very formal
like church spanish mom and dad spanish
so i reminded them of their kids and
grandkids and during the writing of the
book i had like pink hair purple hair
green hair
and they and i had these tattoos and
some of them would be like
you have a lot of tattoos what do your
parents think about that and i was like
what do you think my parents think about
that
and you know it just became like i was
myself around them and i just reminded
them of
their kids and grandkids who assimilated
and
who they were just shaking their heads
at you know
it was i looked like them i had their
same status like
it it um the yale thing
didn't mean anything to them they were
proud of it some of them had never heard
of the school
and they were like um
they knew that i worried that i that i
worked hard in order so that i could be
able to help my parents out financially
and that meant a lot to them
the gay stuff i didn't volunteer it
um but i said i talked about my partner
it helps that
pronouns don't often come up in spanish
but
um i would be like oh yes i have to go
to my partner
and uh blah blah if someone i felt was
extremely religious
i would um say partner and repeat
partner and avoid pronouns
but um most people i
i was just open with because i felt like
if
they were uncomfortable with me
being queer and
being this like we wouldn't have the
level of intimacy required
to form the story that we needed to form
together
and i could just find another subject
so last question oli but a goodie
important given
the population the imagined population
audience
for this uh for this conversation is
what advice do you have for aspiring
latinx writers and
if you want to just wrap up into any of
that any closing thoughts
you want to leave us with
i would say um read a lot
um
i would say don't
i would say don't listen to what
hollywood representations of latinx
people
have to say about our own representation
they're not leading the way here i think
we're in a really interesting moment
where immigrant artists and latinx
artists
are trying to do really cool things with
voice and genre
like um i don't know if y'all have read
marcelo hernandez castillo's children of
the land
he's a undocumented author
i think on his way to permanent
residency or something
but he uh he he's a poet and he wrote a
really cool book
um jenny zhang was never undocumented
but um
she grew up in queens grew up as an
immigrant
and her book is vulgar and filthy and
wacky and crazy and and
you know sarvador placencia's
you know i learned from albert is um
you know great book um
don't i would say kill your idols
you know commit matricide and patricide
like
stop looking at julia alvarez and sandra
cisneros and
you know all those ladies and and and
stop stop looking at gloria and zelda
and all of that like it's past that
it's 2020. like start looking elsewhere
for inspiration
like there are some books that i'm
reading that are coming out now
that are still describing our skin as
like dulce de leche skin
and are still saying that our parents
are strong and can handle anything
and that they just like pray to the viet
hang and everything will be okay
and that is tired and
it's this like incestuous relationship
that the publishing industry has with
hollywood
and that is what has created the
backdrop for what we think
we need to sound like and we don't
we don't and you will receive pushback
for not sounding like that
but but but um
but our canon is young our canon is
young
but um but we need to push forward
because um this is like such an
important time to really experiment and
to really support each other
as we create some you know really
powerful art
because if we're creating art where if
you like
take a person who's like been in a
bunker for 50 years and is like
was this produced in the 90s or was this
produced in 2020
and if they can't tell the difference
like
you writing it was a waste of time
well said well that's that's the time we
have today
um mj were you going to jump on for any
closing thoughts
i mean i'm hap thank you carla obviously
uh for taking the time
to chat um thanks everyone for
for logging on for the conversation mj
you want to take the mic here
just want to thank you both so so so
much
it was an amazing event um for our
audiences thank you for joining us
i am linking our social media on the
chat
please follow us there will be many more
events to come
keep in touch so thank you all thanks
for coming
take care everyone